in this video we are going to cover
three topics handl services and
repository pattern middle a and request
context initially the plan was to cover
each Topic in different different videos
so this was supposed to be three videos
but since these three topics are so
closely related with each other in fact
pretty much all the topics are closely
related to each other since we are
talking about backends here but I cannot
go ahead and make a 100 hours video
right so in this case these are in this
case these are very closely rated to
each other and it'll be easier to
explain all three of them in the same
context instead of repeating the same
thing again and again in different
different videos and that's the reason
we are going to cover all three of the
topics in this same video now let's talk
about handlers services and repositories
I know that I have talked about this
topic in different different videos I
have mentioned it in fact I have even
explained it a little bit in other
videos so it might sound a little bit uh
repetitive but uh I have never
officially covered this topic so this is
the time that we can do that okay so
let's start with client and server we
have our client here and we have say
server here okay this is our client and
server and we communicate with each
other over HTTP now when a client sends
a request when it sends a request it
reaches our server so the moment it
reaches our server and until the moment
it receives a response there are a lot
of things happening uh in the server and
we call that a request life
cycle we already talked about the
request life cycle external to the
server like what happens at this point
the sending the request and sending the
response but we have not covered the
request life cycle inside the server
what happens inside the server
throughout the life cycle of the request
so let's cover that what happens now the
request reaches here and we have our
entry point the entry point of the
server the entry the moment our
operating system forwards that
particular h P request to the particular
Port it can be 3,000 it can be 4,000 any
port that your server is running your
operating system forwards that request
to your server and the request reaches
your server that is the entry point of
your request now what happens your
server must be doing some kind of listen
on some particular port and that's how
it gets the request at the start of the
request what happens we have routing
after the request reaches our server
entry point we have routing mechanisms
we have different different routes for
example users then we have users sl12
three we have Dynamic routes and etc etc
we have already talked about routing and
all it reaches our routing algorithm and
depending on the routing
algorithm we map that request to a
particular Handler Handler is basically
any function that we have predefined
that is supposed to handle the request
of that API we have mapped some kind of
function for this as a Handler for this
route now we have the concept of
handlers or controllers services and
repositories and why do we have three
separate components why don't we only
have a single Handler which does all the
stuff and the thing is we can have that
there is no uh requirement that we have
to separate out
the responsibilities into three
different components there is no hard
requirement it is just a design pattern
so that your code base is scalable it is
more maintainable and it is easier to
add features and it is easier to debug
things right now let's see what are the
responsibilities of these three
components the first level once we get
the request here uh from the routing
algorithm it reaches the Handler or the
controller so we have here Handler slash
controller okay what is the
responsibility of this we get the
request and in pretty much all the
servers does not matter you're dealing
with goang or nodejs or python those are
the three languages that I have
personally used so I'm not aware how the
pattern Works in other language but I'm
pretty sure is is an established pattern
right uh in each Handler you will
receive at least two objects or two
variables depending on what programming
language
that you are using you'll receive two
objects or two variables one is the
request object one is the response
object and the Handler can take out
values from that HTTP request from the
request object and it can send responses
and it can modify response headers etc
etc using the response object this is
why we get these two objects and we
don't necessar add these two objects
ourselves the the runtime the
programming language that you are using
if you're using go then go provides
these two objects to you uh by default
on your handlers parameters and
similarly for noes also if you're using
Express or anything like that you will
get this request and response provided
to you you don't have to add them you
will get them for each request now what
happens at the entry point of Handler
what is the first thing that comes to
your mind that we need to find what is
the request about we already know that
what is this API supposed to do because
this API was routed to a particular
route above here and we got this in this
particular handle so we know that what
particular API that this client is
trying to call we already have that part
of the information now we want to take
out different different values so that
we can process the request and send a
response accordingly we can do different
uh database operations we can do
external Logics we can do external API
calls we can do uh we can send emails we
can send notifications we can do a lot
of things inside our uh processing logic
and we have to send a response or we
don't have to send a response depending
on what kind of request it is if it is a
delete request then uh restful standards
say that you have to send a response
code of 204 no content uh with an empty
response body depending on that we can
decide what response now at the entry
point what is the first thing that comes
to your mind that you have to take out
the data from this request object that
is the first responsibility of a Handler
of a controller so this is what you have
to keep in mind again this is not a
necessary requirement you can do
everything in your Handler SL controller
but in a typical backend architecture
this is how how we structure it to make
it more skillable now the first entry
point of your controller or Handler your
responsibility is taking out the data
from the request object depending on
what kind of request it is if it is a
get request if it is a get request you
have to take out the query params right
if it is a post request you have to take
out the request body similarly for
delete we can take out the request body
and for put or patch we can also take
out the request body depending on what
kind of request that is we can take out
the request body that is the first
responsibility of a Handler or a
controller now we've already talked
about serialization and deserialization
and there is the reason we are following
this order we are trying to trace the uh
flow of the request from top to bottom
right the request started from the
client and that's why the first thing
that we covered was how HTTP life cycle
work works right then we went into uh
routing then we went to serialization
and deserialization then validation and
Transformations etc etc right we are
following the request from the top until
it reaches our repository or our
database layer okay we already know that
we have do some kind of serialization
and deserialization at this point
because the request the client sends a
request and that request is serialized
into a Json format because it has to
travel over the internet and Json is a
serializable format that is used across
front end and backend boundaries and
there are other serialization formats
but Json is the most popular one as of
now okay now the first thing that we
have to do in the controller layer
depending on your programming languages
the implementations might be different
but this is a common pattern the first
thing that you have to do is
deserialize the Json object that you
received from the request into your
native data format now if it is a node
just backend then you might not
necessarily do this step there will be a
middleware somewhere somewhere Upstream
before the routing happens which
derealize all the Json into JavaScript
objects right that's why we have Json do
body parer ET ET middle in our node J
apps so that's that's why we don't
necessarily do the Step at the Handler
layer but in other programming languages
like go or python we have to do this
step explicitly we have to deserialize
whatever Json that we receive in the
request into a our native format so if
it's a go app we have to deserialize
into a native struct if it is a python
app we have to deserialize into a
dictionary or a class and similarly for
rust we can disiz into a struct etc etc
right we have to take the Json data and
convert into a format that we can
understand that our programming language
can understand that it has to follow its
native data format this the first thing
that the Handler does takes out the data
from the request object and it
deserializes into the native format of
the programming language that you are
using that is the first step okay this
is also called binding depending on what
framework that you are using but most of
the Frameworks use this terminology
which is called binding the request body
into your native format and and at this
step if the deserialization fails or
some error occurs then we send a request
uh we send a response to the client with
the status code of 400 which is bad
request
use the error code of 400 to tell the
client that this request is not valid
something is wrong with this request
payload right we send the 4and request
and we terminate the request at this
point we don't continue we don't proceed
ahead right first thing now second thing
and again I am talking about an ideal
production grid backend pattern now okay
depending on on the implementation you
might not have a validation layer but we
have already talked about validation and
transformation in a previous video and
the advice is you should validate
everything that is coming inside your
server from an external client
everything starting from your path
parameters to your request body to your
request uh query parameters etc etc
everything that you can validate and be
as specific as possible while you're
validating it
we have already covered these things in
our validation transformation video now
that's the second thing that happens
here once we have deserialized the data
into a native format now we understand
the data our programming language can
make sense of the data it cannot make
sense of the Json data because uh that
is a serializable format and not every
programming language JavaScript has a
very good support for Json because Json
is inspired by the JavaScript object and
it has first support for Json but then
you come to other programming languages
you don't have as uh smooth integration
with Json we have to do a lot of manual
processing right now at the second step
we do validations and Transformations we
take the data that we have bound here to
our native format let's say we are using
go programming lger now we have a struct
if you are using python now we have a
class or a dictionary which contains all
the data that the client has sent but in
our own programming language format the
client is using JavaScript it has sent
using Json but now we have a struct in
go which contains the same data in a
different representation but with the
same values now we take that data and we
validate it we validate it we make sure
that all the data that the client has
sent it is in the expected format all
the mandatory values are sent all the
values that are sent are in the expected
format there is no malicious intent
there is no uh missing values etc etc
everything that we do in a validation
pipeline after we validate it we also
optionally do a transformation what does
transformation mean transformation is
basically after we validate the data
that has come from the client we do some
kind of modifications to make it
convenient for our server to process the
data for example we can set defaults
let's say we have a get AP we have a get
API where we are fetching all the books
we are fetching all the books and there
is a query parameter the client can send
which is sort and in the value can be
name or by date the created date of the
book right these are the values that the
client can send and the require mment is
and this is a good pattern that you
should establish in your backend apps
that query parameters you should try
your best to do all the query parameters
optional right that should be your
requirement that is a good pattern to
establish early in your API design and
we'll cover all about API designs all
the best practices restful architecture
and everything in the next video that is
all about API designs and principles and
how to think about apis how to design
design them etc etc so there you'll have
all your doubts cleared about this how
to structure this how to uh start about
this but just a info for the sake of
this video that you should try to make
all your query parameters in your apis
optional and coming back to
transformation let's say this is the
requirement the client can send two
values in the sort query parameter
either name or date and if the client
sends name you have to sort all the
books by the name of the book books or
if it sends date then you have to sort
by the date of the book at what date
that book was created now in the
transformation pipeline let's say uh
this request went through the validation
and client did not send any query
parameters it just send CL books that is
the URL it did not send any query
parameters in the validation pipeline it
goes through because you have made all
the query parameters optional as a good
pattern so the validation pipeline
succeeds you don't get any errors you
don't send any 400 bad request errors to
your client it goes through now it
reaches your transformation pipeline now
you want to uh make it convenient for
your database layer to process the data
and that is the reason in the
transformation pattern what you can do
if the client has not sent any query
parameters you can set defaults you can
set defaults here which means in the
transformation pipeline what you will do
you will check if there is if there are
no query parameters passed you set the
value of sort as dat or depending on the
requirements you can also set it to name
that's why we use transformation
pipeline so that we can do a couple of
operations on the data that we have
received from the client before it goes
to the database layer or before it goes
to the service layer so that we can make
it more intuitive and more uh convenient
for our down stream layers to process
the data in a more expected way let's
say we did not pass anything then the
service layer has to check if the S
field is passed or not if it not passed
then do this if it is passed then do
this then we have a condition Branch
there so a lot of inconvenience but
still doing this makes your code a lot
more readable it makes your code follow
an expected path of processing that's
why we have validation and
transformation byeline we won't go too
deep into this we have already covered
about this in the previous video that's
the second thing your Handler does now
you have taken out the request object
the request information from the request
object then we have validated the data
you have transformed the data according
to your convenience now you have a solid
data format that is ready to get
processed that is ready to get processed
by your Downstream layers now at this
point what happens the controller layer
controller layer calls the service layer
with all the data that it has properly
validated and transformed it passes that
data to the service layer and all the
information that the service layer might
need to process the data for example the
authentication information like user ID
the user permissions etc etc pass all
those data and then the service layer
starts processing now what happens in
the service layer now the service layer
ideally should not deal with any kind of
HTTP related stuff we try to limit all
the HTTP related stuff in the controller
layer for good reasons that we'll
explore a a little bit later now the
service layer is just a function you can
think of service layer just a just a
function that has nothing to do with any
kind of backend frontend interaction or
such if you take a look at your service
method then from one look you should not
not be able to tell that this is a
function that is being used in an API
that is a good pattern to follow your
service layer should be in isolated
manner should be doing all the
processing and then returning the data
it should take some data process it and
returns and data without worrying about
what Response Code to return to the
client what kind of data it is receiving
should the validation etc etc you should
not have to worry about all those stuff
that is the responsibility of the
Handler layer that's where we draw the
line the responsibility line okay now
what happens in the service layer it
takes all the data that is needed to
process uh that is needed to do all the
operations that we want to do then what
it does it calls the repository method
for your database operations if that is
needed there are of course service
methods for example if this service is
only supposed to send an email to some
client or to some user then what does in
the data it might be receiving the email
address and it takes that email address
it executes the logic which sends the
email to the client and it then returns
a response that looks something like
this success is true to your Handler
back it can also do something like this
without calling the repository method we
also have services like this or if it
needs to deal with databases whether it
needs to persist some data or whether it
needs to fet some data from the database
then it uses the repository layer for
that kind of information now at this
point what happens we have the
repository we have the repository layer
or the database layer depending on what
terminology that you and your team is
using the r again takes the data
whatever data that needs to be inserted
or whatever data that needs to be
fetched now all the requirements of the
data for example we received
the parameter sort from Upstream from
our Handler which either has a value
name or has a value date it takes the
data service layer takes the data from
the Handler and it passes the data to
the repository layer and the repository
layer takes the data and it construct
the database query the sole
responsibility of repository layer is it
takes whatever the data that has to be
inserted or it takes all the filtering
data the Sorting data whatever data that
is needed to fetch dat from database
takes all the data it constructs the
database query and it returns whatever
the result that was return return by the
database it has a single responsibility
take some data performs a database
operation returns it again the
requirement is one repository method
should only return one kind of data
which means let's say uh you have two
repository methods one for getting all
books and one for getting a single book
then ideally you should not pass an
optional parameter in the same function
and depending on the optional parameter
you should not return a single book or
you should not return all books you
should not do that repository methods
have a single responsibility if that
repository method uh needs to return all
books then it should return all books
and if needs to return a single book
then it needs to take the idea of that
book and it needs to return the single
book that's how you should design your
repository methods so that the service
layer we have the service layer here the
service layer has also service layer
also has the responsibility to
orchestrate which means it can take the
different different data that is
returned by the different different
repository methods and it can like merge
those data take the necessary fields for
different different results and it can
return that data to the Handler okay
that's the responsibility of the service
layer a service layer can use multiple
repository methods it can do different
different operations to merge different
types of data from the database and ET
ET a service layer can do a lot of
things inside this a one service method
but a repository method should do a
single thing is fetch some data
depending on the requirements or insert
some data depending on the requirement
or delete some data depending on the
requirement okay and service layer
orchestrates different different
repository method or it does external
API calling it sends notification it
sends like an email to your user Etc ET
it does everything that an API needs to
do all the actual processing of the API
happens in the service layer handlers
deal with data formats the input data
formats the output data formats the
actual processing happens in the service
layer all the database calls happens in
the repository layer that's how we
isolate the three layers okay now the
service layer called the repository
layer for fetching all the books
depending on the S
parameter it got the response from the
repository layer and it returned that
response to our Handler or to our
controller and we are back from the
service layer the controller layer
called the service layer and it returned
the data the service layer returned data
and now we are back at the controller
layer okay now what all happened one we
did The Binding of the data from the
request in the controller layer we did
validations and transformation s okay
third thing what did did call service
layer which did the actual processing of
the data fourth we got the data what the
next thing to do send response to the
client so as you can see the controller
layer actually controls the data flow
from client to server from server to
client it got the data it did some
validation transformation processed the
data and now it will send the response
an appropriate response back to our user
back to the client and depending on the
success or failure of the service method
whether we were able to process the data
or not the controller layer decides on a
appropriate response code it can be 200
codes uh it can be 200 2011 204
depending on the success it can be any
of the 200 series codes or if there was
a failure then it can also be 400 if it
is a class failure it will be 400 if it
is a server failure it can also be 500
and it is the responsibility of the
controller layer to decide an
appropriate response code and send an
appropriate error message if it was an
error or send an appropriate success
message with the success data in this
case it it will return all the books an
array of books with a response code of
200 because it it was successfully able
to fetch all the books and then it will
send the data back to the client that's
how the request life cycle looks for a
single API call and that's how handlers
SL controllers services and repositories
integrate or cooperate with each other
to process data from a client and send
an appropriate response back that's how
we that's how cut next up we have
middleware in the same context now where
do middleware come in in this whole
picture of a request life cycle now
let's do the whole request life cycle
again but this time we'll use middle ver
and we'll understand how middle W work
and where do they actually come in okay
we have a client let's not imagine
client now let's say we get the request
from a client now the moment we get a
request the moment the request uh
reaches our entry point the moment the
operating system forwards our request to
the entry point our server from that
moment on we can have different
different
functions different different functions
in between like let's imagine these are
break points these are boundaries of
different different functions and we can
have this function then somewhere we can
have our routing route matching stuff
where we forward a particular API call
depending on which route it wants to go
we can have routing here then again
after routing we can also have middle
wees here right these are just different
different boundaries here then we'll
have our Handler service repository
access then after this also we can have
middle here until the response is sent
back to the client now let's imagine
What's Happening Here what are these
boundaries okay we have this boundaries
we we are already familiar about this
part we are doing a routing here and
this part we that we just saw that the
Handler takes the request it takes out
the unnecessary data it does validation
transformation it calls the service
layer service layer does the processing
by using the repository layer for
database operations then it sends the
response back then the Handler sends the
response back to the client we already
understood this part and this part now
what are these things what are these
functions that are coming in between we
call these functions middle ver and from
the name you can take some meaning out
of it that these functions are supposed
to be executed somewhere in the middle
somewhere in the middle of what in the
middle of these things in the middle of
routing in the middle of Handler
services and repositories and in the
middle of sending the response back to
the client these functions are executed
in the middle boundaries of different
different execution environments or
different different exec context that's
why they are called middlewares now why
do we use them what do they actually do
middlewares also like normal handlers
that we have already discussed that an
Handler typically a Handler receives two
things a request and a response by
default in its parameters which is
provided by our programming language or
our framework or our library whatever
that we are using using to build our
server these two objects request object
and the response object that is provided
to the Handler by default by the runtime
environment in case of middlewares also
since these are also one kind of
handlers but with a one additional
capability these also get a request
these also get a response object but
these also get another thing called next
next is a function and we'll come back
to next soon these are the three things
a typical middleware gets by default
from the runtime from the language run
time it gets three things one the
request object one the response object
to modifying the response and stuff and
one is the next function and the use of
next function is we have these
boundaries that we saw that there can be
one middleware there can be another
middleware and then there is the routing
then there is the multiple middle here
or there cannot be a middle from the
routing we can straight up go to Handler
right we can also skip these middlewares
all the middle Wares are optional that's
something you have to keep in mind
middlewares are optional functions that
depending on your requirement that you
can Implement that you can execute these
things may be there and they may not be
there okay depending on your requirement
middlewares receive three objects which
are request response and next next is a
function which is basically passes the
the execution from one middleware to the
next middleware to cross this boundary
from one middleware to next middleware
the runtime gives us one function called
Next and as the name sounds we are just
proceeding to the next mid l or the next
execution function we cannot always say
the next middleware because if we focus
on this execution this is going from one
middleware to our routing or if you
focus on here this going from one
middleware to our handl that's why next
function passes the execution to the
next context whatever context next is
supposed to process the request or is
supposed to process the response next
function call that okay that's the use
of next function it just passes the
execution to the next processing context
that's all about next okay now since a
middleware receives a request object and
a response object you can already
imagine that a middleware can take out
values from your request and it can send
a response back to the client from this
point only the request may not reach our
routing part the request may not reach
after the routing algorithm and it may
not reach to the handlers Which is far
ahead in the request life cycle this
middleware can do some logic and it can
send a response back to the client from
this point on so okay because it
receives a response object from the
runtime that is the capability of a
middleware it can take values out from
request it can modify the values of the
request and it can also send back a
response to the client that's the
capabilities of a middleware now why do
we use middlewares okay why not do
everything in the handlers only why do
we use different different things now
the obvious answer is because the same
reason we use functions why do we use
functions so that we don't have to write
the same set of lines the same set of
lines of execution all the time in
different different places we can just
write those few lines in one function we
can pack that in in one environment then
we can call that function again and
again in different different places
depending on our requirement you can
pass different different parameter to it
and change the order of the execution or
the uh result of the execution but we
can reuse that code in different
different places that's the reason we
use functions in programming same way we
use middleware so that we can do some
logic in our whole API request life
cycle again and again in different
different request so as a backend
application your app receives thousands
or depending on the scale depending on
the popularity of your platform it might
be receiving thousands and millions and
billions of requests every day and
because of that you have to do some kind
of common operations you have to do some
kind of uh security operations logging
operations and authentication operations
and data passing operations for all
those requests now you also as a huge
backend application you also have
hundreds and sometimes thousands of API
end points now for each API endpoint you
will have handlers there is no way
avoiding that you have to write
different different handlers for
different different API points that is
there now if we don't have middlewares
we have to perform the same set of
operations for each Handler we have to
duplicate that code for each Handler and
at this point you might also say that we
can write a function and we can call
that function in every Handler you can
do that but this that is still some kind
of duplication that you have to call
that function in every Handler that is
the reason to minimize that code
duplication to minimize that redundancy
we delegate the responsibility of
dealing with some common operations
whether it is security whether it is
logging whether it is Data passing
whether it is compression all these
different different common operations we
delegate those parts to a different
component of our request life cycle and
we call that middleware functions
middleware functions because they will
be placed in the middle before it
reaches the appropriate component before
it reaches the Handler
and they will do these common operations
and depending on the result of those
operations it can they can even send a
response back to the client before that
request reaches our handlers so that we
don't waste our precious server
resources that's I use middleware number
one uh requirement being to reduce code
duplication now the second thing to keep
in mind is the order of middleware is
important this order is important
because as a request from our client
reaches here at the enter point and
starting from this every middleware
using next function passes the execution
to the next middleware okay it passes
this to the next middleware then it
passes to routing then routing passes
the execution to the next middleware
then then then then then then until a
response is sent back to the client this
all happens using the next MW can use
next function to pass the execution to
the next middle if there is one this
order of passing the execution to all
the different different middle is
important that's how our request will be
processed the order is important now
these are some examples where we use
middleware typically in a backend
application for let's say security
purpose security purpose can be let's
say we have different different
materials let's say we have course then
we have
security headers to add security headers
then we have authentication middleware
then we have rate limit
let's see what each of these middlewares
do then we'll understand why they are a
middleware instead of a common function
we have already understood course uh
course U is basically a security
mechanism a privacy mechanism followed
by the browsers which states that your
application that is running in the
browser cannot access resources outside
of your own origin which means if you
have domain example.com then you can
only access resources from example.com
that is a restriction browser poses on
you as a client now to um bypass that
not bypass necessarily but if the
resource the remote resource sends a
header remote resource sends an
appropriate header which says that your
client is allowed to access the
resources from this server in that case
the browser won't block the response
won't block that request that's why we
have course so that we can limit what
kind of clients at least web apps can
communicate with our servers okay now on
the server side what happens is your
server gets the request from the client
and it has to check the origin of the
request where it is coming from that is
automatically given to us by our runtime
we receive an origin value from where
the request is coming from and depending
on the origin value and depending on
what are the origins that we are
allowing to communicate with us we can
set some headers if it is an allowed
origin that is if it is the front end
domain that is our frontend platform
that is trying to communicate with our
backend platform if that condition is
true if it is our frontend platform in
that case we want to add the appropriate
headers we have covered this whole
workflow in our HTTP video right in the
back end from first principles uh
playlist that you can watch to
understand how the course flow works we
don't want to go too deep into this
since it is about a different topic now
you want to add this particular headers
that will tell the browsers that it is
allowed this request should be allowed
in the same origin policy now we want
that to happen if the origin matches our
frontend origin if that condition passes
through we and want to add those headers
and then we want to pass that on to the
next middleware as we have already seen
as we have already seen here each
middleware does something and passes
that request to the next middleware or
it can send the response back to the
client at this point in the course
middleware what happens it gets the
request it takes out the origin It
checks if it is our front end domain if
it is our front end domain it adds some
headers to our response to our response
object it adds our some response headers
that there is the allowed Origins and
Etc then it passes that to the next
execution environment or for the next
middleware okay if it does not match
then we don't add any headers and the
browser will block the request by
default when we send the response back
to the client okay now the question is
why did we make this as a middleware
because this is a function that needs to
happen that needs to get executed for
each API call that our server will
receive that is the first requirement we
want to reduce the code duplication it
needs to deal with the request object or
the response object in this case it it
deals with both it takes the origin out
of the request it modifies the response
headers that is a second requirement
there is some code that needs to run for
each request and it needs to deal with
the request and response object that's
why me made this a middleware so that we
don't have to do this for each Handler
okay this is the perfect requirement for
a middleware that's why course is
usually implemented in the middleware
layer not in the Handler layer okay
similarly we have security headers from
the server we can set different
different security headers for example
content security policy etc etc and we
want to set that for each API call that
we receive that's why we also made this
a middleware it gets the request it adds
the appropriate security headers and it
forwards that to the next middleware
similarly we have
authentication we make authentication as
a middleware because we don't want to
duplicate the function of getting the
token uh usually when we authenticate we
take the token if you have seen the
authentication authorization video in
the pack in from first principles
playlist then you'll understand this
usually in authentication we take some
kind of token can be JW it can be S ID
Etc from the request object and from the
headers or from the payload or whatever
your implementation is we do some kind
of logic to verify whether it is proper
credentials or not whether it is a
proper token or not depending on the
success or failure of that if it is a
failure then we send a 401 unauthorized
error code to the client right from here
without going to our Handler layers
without forwarding the request to the
next middleware we immediately send an
error code back to the client and we
terminate the request right there or if
it was a success what we do we
authenticate we take out whatever
details is is needed for example the
user ID or the permission or the role of
the user whether the user is admin or
not etc etc we take this we add this to
our request context and that's the
reason the request context is our next
topic of discussion we add this
information to our request context and
we forward it to our next middleware we
don't um send the response back to the
client immediately that we do only in
case of failures that's the reason we
make authentication as a middleware so
that for each request and for each
request it verifies the credentials or
the token and accordingly it terminates
the execution or it passes the execution
with the appropriate metadata like user
ID and user role to the next middleware
similarly rate limits rate limits we
Implement so that one client cannot do a
lot of request in a short amount of time
we pred decide a reasonable number
request that a client can send in a
particular period and we add a
middleware which checks that we do that
with IP addresses we check that whether
this IP address has made more than 30
API calls in the last 2 seconds
something like that we decide the
threshold ourselves we decide the
thresholds of the time and what time
period we want to check we also decide
the threshold of the API calls whether
it is 30 API calls whether it is 500 API
calls etc etc and according to that we
Implement our rate limit if the client
exceeds the limit what we do we send an
error code of
429 which basically we send when there
are too many requests from the client we
send an error code of 4 to9 back to the
client saying there are too many rquest
in the short period of time if the
client has not exceeded the limits then
we pass the execution to the next middle
a using the next function okay that's
how that's some of the examples of the
security medal similarly we have logging
middlewares and monitoring logging
middlewares logging and monitoring
middlewares which basically every time
we get an HTTP request let's say we got
got a get request okay we can do some
kind of logging in our server uh in our
terminal or whether a log file so that
we can later on it helps us debug
information it helps us in reports ET
Etc to track different different
parameters for each request this
middleware gets different different
parameters out of that request for
example what is the path we are trying
to access which is users uh what is the
request method which is get what are the
query parameters what is the request
board ET we can log a lot of information
for each request so that it's easier to
deug and it's easier to audit and etc
etc okay that is the example of logging
middle we also have Global error
handling and this is very important uh
you feel every backend application
should some kind of should have some
kind of global error handling so that
what happens it does not matter uh at
what point some error occurs in your
application it can happen in the Handler
layer it can happen in the service layer
or it can happen in any of the
middlewares that are executing in
between in between different different
function boundaries in all these
different different execution
environments does not matter at what
point an error occurs this middle lay
can get that error it will get that
error uh that generic error whatever
happened and from that what it can do it
can find out whether this is a client
error or not we can Define different
different parameters or different
different fields inside the errors to
indicate whether this error was a client
error or this was a server error
something went wrong in our server
execution depending on that it can send
a 400 errors or 500 errors and it can
send a properly structured error message
which usually has a message or some kind
of code so that the front end can render
different different uh userfriendly
messages depending on the code or the ID
sometimes also called ID and the status
back to our client so the goal of the
global error handling middleware is it
takes out an unstructured error from
anywhere from our app and since it is a
middleware it has access to that and
because of the nature of global error
handling middleware usually what we do
in our middleware life cycle we have
different different middleware at
different different points right it is
the entry point this is the first
middleware that happens and this is the
last middleware usually what happens we
keep the error handling middleware at
the last we send a response back to our
client because in all these different
different executions error might happen
in any of these cases so the last
middleware can get that it can check
whether some error occurred if it did
then it can properly structure that
error and send a properly structured
error message back to the client that's
the reason we use error middleware error
close Global error handling middleware
at the last point of our execution as
the last middleware and as I said The
Ordering of middleware is important
because if you use error middleware
somewhere in the middle then if some
error happens in our Handler at this
point then the error middleware won't
have access to that error because the
execution of that middleware was
happening here but our error occurred
somewhere in the here and the request
flows this way okay it flows one way we
cannot get the error back here that's
the reason we should think more about
how we are ordering our middlewares now
coming back we similarly have
compression middle so that uh if you
have a large response let's say we have
a Json which has thousands and thousands
of fields we can use some kind of
compression algorithm like G etc etc to
compress that response and send the
response back typically modern browsers
have the capability to decompress that
response back to a format that browsers
can understand that clients can
understand so that during the transit a
compressed format is in use but during
the client dation process that
compressed format is again converted
into a proper client form for example a
JavaScript project etc etc right we also
use middle in case of compression Etc
similarly for data passing the process
of serialization and deserialization we
can also delegate that to a middleware
so that we don't have to do that in
different different handlers of course
that depends on the requirement of your
backend on your code base and what are
the standards that you use what are the
styling standards that you are using but
you can also do that you can delegate
the validation transformation into a
different middleware the data passing
The Binding of data the serialization
and deserialization data to a different
middleware so these are all the examples
of how middlewares work and as I said
The Ordering of middleware is important
that's the reason typically in our rec
life cycle the first middleware that
gets executed is course because if it is
coming from An Origin that is not
supposed to have access to your server
in that case you want to find out that
information at the early stage of your
request so that you can terminate the
request right here that's the reason
course is executed the early
face then we usually execute some kind
of logging middleware then we have
authentication then at the end we have
Global error handling as I said The
Ordering of middleware is important
depending on how you're structuring your
application and what are your
requirements you should spend some time
in thinking at what order these requests
has to be modified or at what order the
request life cycle should follow to
provide a appropriate experience to the
client which is making the API call and
that's pretty much all about middle
now somewhere at this point somewhere at
this point we talked about the
authentication middleware and how it
stores some kind of information like the
user ID and the user role in some kind
of storage and it passes that to the
next middleware uh to the next Handler
okay and that part is called a request
context is called a request context
request context is also something that
you will see in a lot of backend
applications uh does not whether we are
using nodejs or goang or python etc etc
every framework every language every
Library provides some kind of request
context implementation uh request
context can be an abstract concept um
but it it is also a concrete
implementation the implementation logic
might vary depending on what language or
environment that you're using but this
concept kind of Remains the Same across
different different languages so what is
this concept exactly request concept is
basically some kind of storage or some
kind of state that is scoped for a
particular request that is scoped for a
particular request that is limited to a
particular request so each request so
let's say you have a server you have a
client a client across the worlds you
have hundreds and thousands of clients
and each of them send different
different different different requests
hundreds and thousands of requests for
each client each of these API calls each
of this request will will have a context
attached to them depending on the
implementation of your HTTP server okay
each of them will have some kind of
context and why do we have this context
so that we can have some kind of storage
or some kind of state attached which is
accessible across our middleware and
Handler boundary so as you saw somewhere
early here when the request reaches here
and until the response is sent back to
the client there are different different
function boundaries usually we have
different different middlewares that are
processing here there's a course
middleware there's a logging middleware
then we have routing then we have
authentication middleware then we have
some kind of middleware that is limited
to the application okay some kind of
permission checks then we have the
Handler logic then at the end we have
Global error handling mod etc etc until
response is sent back to the client we
have different different middlewares now
a context a context is typically some
kind of storage usually a key value pair
we store some kind of key value pairs
inside the context so that this
information is accessible by all these
different different execution
environments it is accessible in all
these middlewares now this middleware
can set some value in this context now
this value will be accessible to this
middleware at this point without
explicitly passing those values directly
with without coupling the system
together too closely that's the reason
we have some kind of state which is
accessible by all these middlewares and
all these handlers all of them receive
this context this context or also called
as a state which is limited to this
request and is accessible by all the
execution environments all the
middlewares all the handlers etc etc
okay so that our system is not closely
coupled we have this state this is
accessible by all of them which is
modifiable by all of them some kind of
storage for the sake of convenience so
in this example what we did in the
authentication middleware what we did we
verified the credentials of the user if
it was a login attempt it was the first
time the user was logging in we verified
the credentials the email and the
password and and if it was successful we
created a user if it was an already
existing user we took out the user ID
and we also took out the role the role
can be user or admin or sales any role
right depending on your RB
implementation we have already discussed
RB in our authentication and
authorization video from there you can
uh understand what are roles and why do
use them and also about different
different authentication methods okay so
we have some kind of authentication
mechanism and using which after the
authentication is successful we have
different different information you have
the ID of the user for our platform we
have the role of the user whether it is
a user it is admin Etc have a sales or
different permissions whether the user
has read permission for the resource
whether it is a write permission etc etc
all this metadata about the request and
it is only limited to this request this
particular HTTP request this will be
store in the context so that let's say
your authentication middleware set these
values in inside the context so later on
Downstream your handlers your handlers
which is going to insert so it is a API
which is a post API to the slash books
endpoint so what your Handler can do
somewhere Upstream your authentication
middleware uh verified the credentials
of the user verified the token of the
user and it found out these information
and it saved those information in the
request context now what happens in the
Handler
when the execution reaches your Handler
the Handler can take out this
information the user ID the user role
etc etc and what it can
do it want to insert a book it want to
insert a book into the database so a
book table might have a field called
user ID so instead of taking the value
of user ID from the client from the user
payload instead of doing that what we do
we take the user ID from the authentic
ation information from the result of the
successful authentication we can take
out who is the user that is making this
API call and that's how we take the user
ID and we insert that into the database
and why do we do this because if we take
the user ID from the client a client
with a malicious intent client with a
malicious intent can send the user ID of
some other user to do unexpected
operations in our server that's the
reason when we want to access the user
ID we want to store or when we want to
check different different user related
information we take that information out
of the authentication middleware we save
that into a context and in the
downstream methods in the handlers and
in the next middlewares we take that
user ID and we perform different
different permission checks in the
database layer or in different different
RB layers depending on that information
whether the user has permission to
insert a book or not we can take that
from this if the user is an user if the
user is an admin
so all in all a context is just a shared
state that is accessible to all the
middlewares and handlers so that our
system is not closely coupled and we
have some kind of state some kind of
storage that is limited to one request
similarly uh we can use uh the request
context to store the request ID so
initially somewhere Upstream we can have
a middleware which let's say somewhere
here we have have a middle a somewhere
here where we generate a unique ID let's
say a uu ID we generate a uu ID and save
that in the context so throughout the
execution of this request life cycle we
use this particular ID we take that out
from our context and we use that in
different different information we can
log the ID here and we can use the ID to
make API calls to different different uh
Services let's say it's a microservice
architecture so we can take that ID and
we can
call that API with this ID in somewhere
in the header let's say x request ID or
something like that so that when we are
auditing our logs or when we are
reviewing our logs when we are debugging
something we can trace the request where
it started from which service it started
from all all the services that it called
etc etc right and we can do that because
we have a shared state which is called
request context where we can save
information for that request
okay that is another example of when we
use request context request context we
also use to send cancellation signals
and abort signals and deadlines to our
Downstream external services so that our
service does not hang up
perpetually these are all the use cases
of request contexts that we typically
have in a backin server so that's all
about uh handlers Services repositories
middlewares and request context